qui aurait cru qu'une chef du npd
devienne l'une des plus ardents
défenseurs
la piscine 14 juillet après que l'on ait
les premières ni aux démocrates à la
tête de l'alberta trenton est devenu son
meilleur atout ils sont pire handicap
mais comment en est elle arrivée là
si les nôtres les la politique est une
affaire de famille son père grec note
les a dirigé pendant plus de quinze ans
le parti néo-démocrate alberta il était
très respecté explique ce chroniqueur
politique qui couve la scène albertaine
depuis plus de 30 ans c'est vraiment la
fille de son père elle est très fidèle à
son héritage et comme lui elle défend
les décès pour qu'on vient de drogue
le rêve de son père de devenir premier
ministre s'est elle y réalise
[Applaudissements]
il eût chef du npd en 2014 elles causent
une véritable onde de choc un an plus
tard quand elle met fin à 44 ans de
règne conservateur en alberta la
division du vote de droite et la
lassitude populaire envers les
conservateurs permettent au npd de
passer de 4 à 54 sièges menin des prix
d'honneur expect when le pdi s'attendait
pas à gagner jusqu'à la toute fin
ce sont 10 super on va gagner mais aussi
aux non attendez on va gagner
comment on va faire pour gouverner oui
on est les imprime sa marque sur la
province
elle hausse le salaire minimum à 15
dollars et elle met en place un plan de
lutte contre les changements climatiques
qui prévoit la fermeture des centrales
au charbon d'ici 2030 et l'instauration
d'une taxe sur le carbone la lune de
miel avec les environnementalistes et
courte durée d'un côté madame nakhlé
désirent connaître les changements
climatiques veut lutter contre et
propose malheureusement l'expansion du
principal problème environnemental au
pays soit la production pétrole des
sables bitumineux par cairn energy a
choisi son camp ne partira pas en guerre
contre une industrie qui représente le
quart du pib de sa province
normal dit l'une de ses plus proches
conseillères c'est le rôle du
gouvernement de gouverner pour tous
l'étude tous les gens c'est pas le rôle
du gouvernement de 2 jusqu'à trop
partisan la guerre elle vient plutôt
avec d'autres chefs du npd
le premier ministre de la
colombie-britannique opposé à
l'expansion du pipeline trenton dans sa
province et leader fédéral john mensah
un conflit qui illustre une division
profonde dans l'identité néo-démocrate
croit cet ancien stratège de thomas
mulcair
le npd est une vaste coalition et une
partie du npd qui est
tradition comment dire de la classe
ouvrière de créer des emplois qui
appuient la construction du pipeline et
donc qu'ils appuient madame nakhlé
l'autre camp baisser le camp des
environnementalistes ceux qui veulent
faire de la lutte au changement
climatique une priorité
une chose est sûre pour être honnête les
le fait d'avoir défendu corps et âme
l'expansion de 30 centimes lui a permis
de montrer sa détermination et sa pointe
de faire c'est elle qui a forcé qui a
cajolé qui a intimidé justin trudeau
pour qu'ils achètent le pipeline elle ne
laissait pas tomber sa montré qu'elle
était une leader fort et si tu aimes
chanter n'est devenu le symbole de son
engagement envers les albertains c'est
aussi le projet qui risque de causer sa
perte
le problème c'est que l'expansion du
pipeline est toujours pas fait c'est pas
la faute de reach la clé une opposition
et les entreprises peuvent l'accusé
d'avoir été irresponsable
d'abord créer une taxe carbone alors que
le pétrole albertain est vendue à rabais
et que l'économie ne se porte pas très
bien
et contrairement aux élections de 2015
la droite est maintenant unique derrière
l'ancien ministre fédéral g5 kenny
sans l'oléoduc sans grande crédibilité
économique auprès de bien des électeurs
votent jour note les mises sur ce qui
lui reste sa personnalité elle est
d'ailleurs plus populaire que son parti
explique ce politologue
d'abord parce qu'elles n'ont aucune
capacité d'empathie qui est assez
impressionnante
c'est à dire que n'apparaît jamais
condescendante malgré qu'elle défend ses
idées on voit qu'elle un excellent
contact aussi avec la population et ce
n'est pas forcé
pas certain que ce lien avec les
albertains lui permettra de garder le
pouvoir
même si le npd aimerait prouver que son
élection il ya quatre ans n'était pas un
simple accident de parcours
[Musique]